I'm sorry I'm laughing in my head
because like he like lost family
remember like that now second questions
like would you rather [ __ ] your mom
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up everybody we are here for
another amazing episode of the careful
boys today we have Steve back in the
room hey
Rich
what happened he's got an even bigger
necklace a thicker chain they say you
are what you wear yeah you got to
project wealth Amazon
so uh today we're going to be talking
about dream guests we would love to
bring on this show Jesus Jesus if you
have if you have any suggestions throw
it in the comments if they're bad
suggestions we won't there's lots of
I've seen lots of suggestions from
people about who we should have yeah
what are some top ones give us both the
best and worst I always like it when
people don't understand how connected we
aren't that's one thing that's my
favorite it's like why don't you guys
get um you know the number one tuber
right now it's like yeah dude because he
because he'll tell us to go [ __ ] her
okay look at her numbers and spit in her
face yeah I've I have responded that way
sometimes I'm like hey if you know him
please connect us have Mr Beast on I'm
like yeah Mr Beast
um would tell us to go die in a fire
after he gives us all Xboxes
he gives us all ten thousand dollars it
would be the die in a fire holding an
Xbox challenge for ten thousand dollars
so Joe Rogan then we should probably get
Joe Rogan yeah
going on Joe Rogan I'm like I'm like
yeah dude that's right yes seven more
mics it feels like everyone goes
everyone that comes here first goes on
there afterwards and we're like how come
they get to go but we don't we know why
oh you don't know why why I see oh what
do you mean we're big enough for Joe
Rogan oh is that what it is yes but
there's people smaller than us that are
going there's people bigger than us that
haven't been on yet okay that's true
whoa dude it's a lot of things
mind-blowing dude let's just get Dave
Chappelle we can get Chappelle Lacey
same same we have a we have our show how
does it come back I love Chappelle Lacy
he's been back here once right yeah once
or twice we've had a few cheerleaders is
there anybody that like kind of seems
likely that we could get probably
Michael Jordan
he's not doing anything these days we're
tired isn't he my friend works at the
Mike Tyson podcast like he runs his
podcast and I was like oh cool then you
could bring him on JK and he goes he
just goes to me and then he goes hey uh
you know Joe Quinn I'm like why because
Mike Tyson wants him on his podcast and
I'm all like why doesn't Mike Tyson DM
him himself yeah he's [ __ ] Mike Tyson
Mike Tyson doesn't need a liaison of JK
news to get to Mike Tyson doesn't need
to DM anybody because he's got people to
DM for him I guess so maybe that's Mike
Tyson's attitude but he's he's so wrong
or maybe Mike Tyson don't know how to
type maybe he's insecure yeah maybe he's
like a big fan he goes oh I don't know I
knew it was coming out I loved it I
don't know if he'll he'll he'll accept
me I don't know I think we should just
get Ben Shapiro your Ben Shapiro be good
yeah I think I'd be lectured a lot he
was recently on uh Lex that's a guy I
want to have dude Lex is great dude I
think we can get Lex bro I think we get
like I think we could get one I think
he'd be a fun hang the first thing I
want to ask him is get him why is a
young man like you why is a young man
like you always in a suit
that's what I want to ask okay he'll
love that he came here
especially we're like okay now we need
you to stand up because we're getting
the hot seat here I'll be like what the
[ __ ] it's like I'm firing all my people
as soon as I get up and then the first
thing is so would you rather [ __ ] your
mom or your dad and he's like that's an
actually a very intellectual question
what's like I want to start really
really cold with you first and then it's
like he's like um what's your favorite
uh letter that starts with a
not even word
what's your favorite
and he's like oh [ __ ]
I know who you are here that's Bula dude
oh dude how's Bola we can't if we can't
get Joe Rogan because they're the same
level we can't get [ __ ] Hospital
we'll never get hospital no way cause
bullet was on Barstool and then he
punched that guy he punch him in the
face he's always [ __ ] fools up I
think a hospital would kick the [ __ ] out
of all of us because blue would be our
Dream guest I would have to say he's
like top he's number one but we couldn't
communicate with him we need a
translator would you want Eddie Bravo on
here Eddie bro oh yeah any problems you
get Eddie good old Eddie can we have
Eddie on but then the whole time just
ask how we can get to Rogan
I almost drives him so you can link us
up or all six of us pin him will he
recommend us yeah
that must drive him insane like being
Joe Rogan's best pal and then like
everyone who talks to you it's like
great let's get to the point dude yeah
yeah when are you gonna ask me if the
Rogan hookup yeah yeah must be wild or
they just go like how's Rogan doing you
know they do it's like was it like Bobby
Lee asking Bert Crusher like hey I want
to go on Rogan and Bert's like yeah just
call them and Bobby's like what
do you mean do you think Bobby will come
back I don't know where about Bobby's
been people want Bobby leave back on
here though I know I have received so
many messages about that [ __ ]
I don't know Bart talked to Bobby the
most so we got to ask Bart
Liu
simu 2 Bart talks to everybody it's
funny because Bart's like the most
Bart's the most anti-social but he's
also the most social when I'm when I'm
like bar how'd you get this guys I don't
know I just messaged him in his DMS yeah
I was like every time yeah but also he's
in charge of the production so it kind
of makes sense that makes sense yeah if
we got simu and then we surprised him
with the David So Cameo
they just hash it out that's gonna be a
crazy like we have a surprise guest it's
like now this is part of the not the
part of the hot seat where the 13 minute
Mark where we bring out a surprise guest
yeah it's the David So minute it's just
David criticizing see Shang Chi it's
David's movie reviews
with you that would be kind of good who
do you want Colleen you've been silent
you're using it yeah
who are your top guests Hannah Gatsby I
think she wants on here Hannah gats
people just kidding liberal comedian oh
yeah that's good all right and then on
what's
let's just have those three I don't know
dude I just feel like inviting Ben
Shapiro's like inviting like your
teacher
the way you said that too yo he's
younger than us too yeah it is but he
acts how old is he uh he's got to be in
his like early 30s or something no way
dude he's like 45. well maybe not
younger than you but he's like 45 years
old no [ __ ] way you don't have any
Anthony that you want to bring on here
yeah
one day I'm I'm sure we'll maybe get
Jackson dude I feel like Jackson who the
[ __ ] is that you know
she's a [ __ ] rock of the world he
straight up said he wants to come here
and he wants to he wants to Duke it out
with Joe because Joe said he's 40 years
old dude I feel like he's a fun Hank
too and literally people are in the
comments asking about JK news and stuff
and he watches he watches a lot no
offense Jackson they're really bad at
pitching people
I asked like 17 times who's who's this
Jackson Michael Jackson he's the Chinese
Rock not the number one like pop
Superstar I had him [ __ ] confused
oh my man
and blame me I don't I'm not your
audience now you're [ __ ] that's true
that's true he's like the coolest Dude
too he's like but he wants to fight me
let's go singer dancer everything what
um he is Olympic level fencing yeah see
you know the guy I'm talking about the
Jackson Wings
former Pop Style Jackson Wang I think
you said it though okay now I believe
you sure 40 year old pop star you
talking about like Psy or something no
I'm talking about the guy that used to
be popular
no he's Taiwan like a Chinese pop star
no he talked to us he talks to a [ __ ]
oh Vanessa
he's 40 something I think he's 40 yeah
yeah that's what I was thinking Family
Guy you're a huge fan yeah
what's his [ __ ] name
yeah this is sick though but that's why
I got Jackson Wang and Venice woo mixed
up and [ __ ] got it got it because it's a
Taiwanese pop star they're like two
generations apart yeah well I don't
listen into that [ __ ] that's what don't
be racist keep defending yourself was
anybody in this room into skateboarding
at all yeah we got Tony Hawk oh I bet we
can get Tony Hawk you think we get Tony
Hawk I don't know and the whole time we
just asked him to do a kickflip what
about what about day one song
that's old school day one song I'm
trying to get him onto our podcast
because we we got a merch so he was like
repping like ninja stuff we kept on
trying to get him on his podcast our
podcast but he kind of like ghosted us
tell him to JK needs first okay let's
get chatted what can they but can they
talk though that's the question you can
skate we could just get him do kickflips
whole time yeah just just cut it in
between the talking oh you know who I
would like to get uh that [ __ ] uh
Asian kid arm wrestler that's destroying
everybody oh the hot dog eater kid too
oh yeah Kobayashi he's the best you
called him a kid isn't that the old as
[ __ ] yeah he's old is he Kobayashi yeah
not old but like I'm old you don't like
Joey Chestnut he's the guy who took his
crown oh he did I remember that he's
like the top G right now he's a top dog
all right nevermind I don't want to get
Kobayashi
Chestnut you want that guy huh what
about from like the fighting scene if
you have somebody from the fighting
scene right here who would it be Nick oh
dude I would love to have hubby bro I
would love to talk to Habib but what
would you ask him so like what like
Muslim like what's the deal
Islam like what's the deal I'm thinking
about transferring over it are these
[ __ ] breaks of uh to see her hosting
him oh man I hope I don't die for some
reason no like fighting you wouldn't ask
him what his favorite color is it's not
dude that'll be my first question Joe
absolutely who's that guy with a lot
[ __ ] tons of muscles the liver King oh
do the liver King you think when you get
liver King I think he's a wild boy
though he won't give us a straight
answer I wish we were able to get the uh
Detroit urban survival guys yeah we
almost did yeah or just Steven Seagal in
general oh my God Stevenson Gall would
be nuts you know what my luck is you
guys be doing videos with students go
and I'm you know I'm in Las Vegas and
I'm like oh like oh yeah sorry you
weren't on the Block this week and I'm
like you guys got students to go I
wonder if I could play I could ask my
friend if Randy Couture would come on
dude go away yeah my friends uh his his
wife
what
see dude Ryan has all the hookups
he's like oh like my friend is his wife
yeah yeah I could ask that would be kind
of cool Ryan's a [ __ ] Dos Equis man
for real I'd be like Randy Couture how'd
you learn all that all that wooden
acting
[Laughter]
was it okay
was it all right we gotta try to bring
it back
I think I've ever seen him make that
face so who are some of the worst guests
holy Shore I would say yeah
and I think that's fine to say spitball
and just spitballing this format's not
for everybody he didn't like being here
right no no he was by the way I don't
blame him no he said it himself no I
used to have to drive here from like
Hollywood he came in in a bad mood and I
think like he was just going through a
hard time at the time and like maybe
he was insecure about the YouTube
audience it was just fresh so I was just
like yo man like it's chill like our
audience knows who you are like we're
not we don't have an audience of 10 year
olds like you think like like our our
fans are like in their 30s like yeah
they're gonna remember you don't worry
about it he was nervous about that he
was very nervous because he thought he
didn't get made fun of no he thought
that the audience is a bunch of 12 year
old teeny boppers that because that is
that is the main YouTube audience
YouTube is a younger audience but I was
like not the reason why you're here is
because a lot of our fans will remember
you yeah and then so after that he was
like okay let's do this he was supposed
to do like much longer but I think like
after a while he's just like no I'm done
remember though he also walked into this
glorious office like I said there's a
lot there's a lot of factors like
driving all the way from Hollywood to
here sucks sometimes because it's an
hour and a half it has nothing to do
with JK it just sucks to come all the
way in traffic yeah so I get it right
and then you show up and you don't know
anybody we have like a little group we
have a good group mind and then you're
the odd Man app so I get that too but
like just just be cool don't be like
kind of he came in he was hot to Bart
immediately and that's when I was like
oh [ __ ] this guy all right he was mean
to Bart immediately Bart just like told
a Bart just told like a you know like
when you're bullshitting in a room where
you don't know anybody yet like Bart
just told like one of those like little
jokes about how um you remember what
exactly what it was Joe I don't remember
I just remember the demeanor was pretty
like there was an attitude problem yeah
and I was like no one's ever been this
rude when they walked in never like it
was immediately I I mean I took it as
insecurity because the questions were
like oh are they gonna know who I am and
then maybe it was just like he shielded
up because he was afraid about the
audience but then but then it continued
on and I thought that we'd be cool after
that conversation but it was just like
he was just being mean and we're just
like why what is this like and in the
specific meanness was just he would just
be staring at like like we're all
riffing and he's just staring staring
yeah not a part of the of the group just
having a conversation or trying and you
kept we would lob things like
he'd like to set it up for a minute yeah
just the ball Falls he doesn't even want
to be part of it so I was like whoa and
he did one of these like
like that yeah it was like that yeah and
it was like dude we're trying to
entertain
I don't know what's going on but like
what the [ __ ] did you say something when
the cameras were off like hey maybe
maybe I think the room was just trying
to process what was happening and we
needed to we needed to shoot so we were
just going going and then like he was
just like I'm out of here and then so
after the door closed we were like whoa
what the [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ]
just happened you guys should have tried
more like quotes like wheeze the juice
or something like that
he probably would have loved that
problem is I forgot so many of them like
I really did it was years ago yeah it
was so long ago Dude I [ __ ] love
Encino Man I haven't seen it in so long
I really like I'm sad that that's what
happened I loved it I loved it to his
point though it is you know even with
other guests and stuff sometimes it is
difficult to come in here and like just
join in the banter I think when we do
like our otrs we talked about this
before right or we're actually like you
know the guest is here we're addressing
a lot of the topics about them if
they're like whether it be Hollywood
real estate whatever we're talking about
that topic it's really easy to like kind
of Riff with people that they don't know
then suddenly we get into like man gets
eaten by an alligator and blah blah and
they're like what the [ __ ] am I doing
here that's true yeah that's a good
point that's a good point and we're like
hey we got like 18 more videos of this
all right you good okay to play Devil's
Advocate don't you think these people
accepting or going on to a commentary
show or whatever it may be wouldn't they
do their research prior and then and
then
you would think you would think you
would think they would be like maybe
this isn't for me and I'll do it Steve I
don't want to hear it
you do you do it actually it's a
compliment to you
[Laughter]
this guy's good he's so good I can I can
hook these whites so easy that's the
that's the bait all women's side yeah
wait a second he understands us look
half of this [ __ ] half of the [ __ ] that
you hear YouTubers talking about like
products wise they just read about
[ __ ] three seconds before they're
talking about it there's no way they're
sitting there doing research about the
shows I promise you I promise you that
[ __ ] that's paying them that [ __ ] they
probably left saying like yelling at
their publicist I can't believe you
brought me on this [ __ ] circus [ __ ]
where is it I'm booked Monterey Park how
long hour and a half the bathrooms are
dirty
but here's what I don't get right
it's in there regardless so so here's
the thing it's like
regardless of what's going on and how
you judge it yeah you got to be at least
like a decent level like we all have a a
common decent respect for each other yes
but the way that
you know he was acting that day was just
flat out rude yeah and it was it was
just it was like there was no point
that's what I thought there was no point
to be that rude bar was being nice did a
friendly little one everyone was trying
to lift him up and like support his
insecurities and come you know just just
be like yo man join in it's good and and
I was like what the [ __ ] yeah it was
weird so that was the weirdest kind of
encounter I've had with with a person
that's sits sat here before you know
what I think I think we should do a
Redemption for probably sure dude he's
welcome to come back and I'm down to
talk about it too because I was just
like like hey what was going on in your
life can I say anything to that one oh
oh I I believe I'm a big-time believer
s in the USA this is the land of the
second chance see thank you I believe in
that and I don't take any I'm not taking
it personal because I I'm I know that
during that time
um I think that's when he lost his mom
or dad too or like it was right around
that air so so I know I know we should
have led with that Joe [ __ ] now I feel
like man I didn't like it I don't know
it could have been a year no dude
Redemption it could have been a year
could have been a lot of different
reasons all I'm saying is I know people
have life right so you're allowed to be
a dick from a time to time but then like
I'm not taking it personal I just don't
know what's going on and he couldn't
keep it together that's all like talk to
me baby yeah talk to me it's like if you
can't keep it together you're gonna
you're going through a hard time you're
being rude to other people mean and [ __ ]
like that's [ __ ] up I'm sorry I'm
laughing in my head because like he like
lost family remember like that now
second question is like would you rather
[ __ ] your mom
it's a it's a staple of JK news that's
why you lead with that question you have
to answer if you're gonna sit in this
chair go to your head oh you know you
know who I would like uh uh Sun Kang oh
yeah man he's so cool do you know this
no yeah uh Fast and Furious he looks mad
he's like no I was just thinking about
it I was like no okay so the Asian dude
are fast and furious who like dies but
he doesn't die Oh Yeah from the you're
talking about from Tokyo Drift yeah and
then he comes back comes back in like
the last one his name is
oh dude and drift King dude would be
cool oh dude people call me DK sometimes
makes me feel wasn't his hot girlfriend
like a a super she's done really well
right
together
I didn't watch Tokyo Drift
it's not until it's later that he gets
with her Joe's back everybody Joe's back
that's a joke clip bro that's a joke it
only happens in Wonder Woman Tokyo Drift
I was like that's a classic I watch
Tokyo Drift I didn't watch did you see
two one or two women
jeez this guy give him a raise
200. cut our pay give him a raise
whatever's left
okay shake the pennies out of my check
into this guys into this guy's check
dude
come on let me give him my bank card
come on dude hey you got to do another
dummy too man
we're gonna have to redo the whole thing
[Music]
thank you